the shocking news is the most appalling
act of violence that's taken the lives
of young people who were at a music
event to enjoy themselves people must be
allowed to enjoy themselves at a music
event this is an appalling act of
violence against people and it must be
totally and unreservedly and completely
condemned during the night
I've been following events and I spoke
to the Prime Minister
early this morning and we discussed the
danger to people the security needs and
also the great work done by the police
the fire and the ambulance services in
supporting people during the night any
support needed by any of our services
must be given and we must support those
people that have suffered so much those
families that have lost young ones those
families that still don't quite know
what is happening with their own
children this is the most terrible and
traumatic time in these circumstances we
have to come together in these
circumstances a city and a community
comes together in solidarity and in
strength so we carry on
we don't allow these attacks in these
people to divide us or prevent us from
leading the decent normal lives that we
all want to lead I spoke to the mayor of
Manchester Andy Burnham about this
overnight as well and he sent out a very
strong statement saying exactly that and
he also thanked cities all around the
world that have sent their solidarity to
Manchester today as indeed I do myself
and your message I'm terribly sorry
terribly sad for you there can be
nothing worse than losing a child in a
situation like this we have to put our
arms around them and support them not
just today but in all the very difficult
days to come because trauma like this
doesn't go in a day or two it's there
with them for the rest of their lives we
have to give them all the support we
possibly can and also make sure we live
in a safe environment in the future and
we live in safety together but we do not
allow our communities to be divided by
this kind of appalling atrocious act of
cat